Now we get to add a second
view controller to our app.
Adding another screen and
view controller to manage that screen
is just what we need to turn pitch
perfect into the app we want.
Open the library panel
here on the bottom right.
If you don't see the library panel,
make sure you have the objects
library button selected.
It's the third one from the left here.
Drug our view controller onto
the storyboard, like this.
You may want to position
it as I have here
to the right of the records
view controller.
Let's make it clear we're
going to the new screen.
We can use our old trick of changing
the background color of the new
view controllers view so
that it's something other than white.
Here I've selected the view
controller and it's view.
You can see Storyboard has automatically
zoomed in to the second view controller.
With this view selected, I'm going to
change the background color to something
other than white, in my case, green.
Set it to whichever
color you prefer just so
that it's something other than white.
Now, we need to make storyboard
transition from our recording view
controller, which is just called view
controller, to our new view controller.
For now, what I want is to connect
it to the stop recording button.
First, select the stop recording
button here in the document outline.
Then you can hold down
the control key and
drag directly from it to
the new view controller.
Select the show segue.
You should see the new symbol with
the arrow connecting the two view
controllers, seen here.
This is called a segue.
Remember we previously wired
up the stop recording button
to the stop recording function,
VN IB action.
It means the stop recording
button is doing two things.
It will call the code in our
recording view controller and
it will also cause the segue to occur,
moving us to the next view controller.
Now you may be thinking yourself,
wait a minute, where is the code for
that green view controller?
We never created any class.
You're correct.
Storyboard is using
the default UI view controller,
not a subclass that you wrote.
And there's just a plain UI view
of which we've changed
the background color.
Let's run this app and see.
If we click Tap to Record and
then Stop the Recording, we can see
that the Ui navigation controller
has transitioned us to the second
view controller, that's green.
Take a moment to notice the new bar,
called a navigation bar, and
the back button labeled Back.
This is a pre-built back button that
will return us to the previous view
controller, a sort of
breadcrumb if you will.
We have just scratched the surface
of UI Navigation Controller.
Because that is all we need for
now in order to build out
the pitch perfect app.
In UI fundamentals you're going to
learn about UI Navigation Controller
in much further detail.